two inflections
like that's that's all you've got now of
course
if we didn't know anything about this
like if they hadn't given this as a lead
in how would you show that there are two
inflections how would you go about doing
that
you can go the second derivative
wouldn't you um you'd solve for when
it's equal to zero
which you can see what is the second
derivative by the way what is this
oh i just did it
when you do d squared y on dx squared
let's just quickly do it again so it's
gonna be v
u dash
yeah did i do it right yeah i reverse
the order that's i'm getting confused
plus
u
what's v dash two h minus minus
there you go right um you can go ahead
it looks to me when i factorize this out
i'm going to get a quadratic there we
should better have two solutions right
and then off i go
and i will show that there's two places
where it's zero and then i need to show
that it actually changes right that's
the way i would go about it
but clearly let me read the wording for
you again because you'll get questions
like this basically examine the behavior
of y as x approaches infinity done
and hence deduce you have two words
there that kind of fence you wins
hence
deduce right so the first thing the
hence means you have to use this in some
way and appealing to the second
derivative pretty much ignores this like
i don't need this fact to use the second
derivative okay and secondly like
they're saying it has some kind of
logical connection right so how do i how
do i pull this in okay yeah is it like
because that curve it has to have an
intercept at negative one it has to
touch the axis at negative one
and then after that it's gonna go up
obviously but then after that as y as x
approaches infinity it's gonna start
going back down to zero so there's gonna
be like one
two points okay all right you're on the
right track you are on the right track i
i wouldn't probably i'm not sure if the
way that you said it would be an
adequate explanation like i don't know
how many people are oh of course
it's so obvious to me now i am going to
start to draw a picture in a second but
i hope to make it clear but before i do
that
you could have
so originally you have one inflection in
between the two okay
yeah before you go on before you go on
there are two inflections right and this
is the first important point and i was
going to mention it so since you have
said it i might as well
when you know this right a minimum and a
maximum they each have concavity right
they each have concavity a minimum is
concave
up
a maximum is concave down
now
that's actually good morning that's
actually not enough by itself to know
that there is a change in concavity
because i'm missing something something
that is very very pointless
that's right
here is a graph
here's a graph it's got a maximum on one
side and a minimum on the other but
there is no point in inflection
why not because it doesn't have a common
middle like joining yeah that's right
there's no actual point that i can point
to like there's a changing concavity but
there's nowhere i can say oh there it is
because there's no there right there's
an asymptote okay
every morning
it's a library yeah
here just the live version okay
so therefore what i actually need to add
on to this because random was there and
i stopped him right this is like it's
like it's like the lego room it's like
you didn't let me finish i died
i need to show this continuous but that
is not difficult once i've done that
see there is a change of concavity
between these number one there's my
first point inflection
okay do you want to continue
so um your second point of reflection
because it's it goes negative minimum
and then positive is um maximum so at
the positive side
it's concave down and because it needs
to approach the axis it needs to curl
back around to flatten out again
did you catch that yeah that was it
wasn't it right let me see if i could
draw a picture for you
what's the only way that this
and this can fit together right if
you're going to approach this is a we
have we have language for this that's a
horizontal asymptote right a horizontal
asymptote so you've got
this kind of shape but you've got to get
to that
you have to get to that i've already
shown that there's not going to be
another stationary point over here right
because i've found i found both of them
so the only thing you can possibly do is
turn from concave down down
to be concave up
like that in order to curl towards
that's actually the right language to
curl towards this asymptote okay so
are you ready can we make the deduction
how would you wet it okay so here's my
wording it's not quite finished on the
board but the part that's missing is the
part that i think you guys can do on
your own
the way i would say it is i have to put
together like note the two facts that
i'm putting together which is the part
that we discussed in detail the part
that i need is the local max and
this horizontal asymptotic behavior that
i'm getting there right so given these
two things there must be a point of
reflection for some value of x
after this to the right of that that's x
is greater than one right in order for
this limit to work right it can't it
can't work unless it inflicts back
upwards right so there's the first point
of inflection or the second depending on
your order in addition for some value
between these two
there must also be a change in concavity
because the curve is continuous and
there's a
concave up point concave down okay and
that's it these are two reflections now
we're ready to draw this thing
because of all the earlier parts we
actually know a lot about this graph for
instance we know that there's a minute
at x equals negative one but negative
one x equals negative 1 is significant
for another reason namely
it's the f
it's it's the x-intercept right so what
i have is a double root at that point so
it doesn't take too much imagination to
see we've already worked out what
happens as x approaches positive
infinity what happens when x approaches
negative infinity
yeah there's no ambiguity there is there
right this guy is racing off and so this
one right so therefore you have this
incredibly steep
behavior
over here to the left of that stationary
point reaches the stationary point just
stops at the axis and then it's going to
come back up where is it going to come
back up to i already know this the
maximum
which is y equals one so i have these
two points right and then i know
at x equals positive one then i'm going
to hit my other turning point now in
order for me to do this properly i do
have to get some vertical scale
happening so here's a value i prepared
earlier
that's the actual now that i'm graphing
now i do need to know where the y value
is so if you pop in x equals 1 you've
got 1 plus 1 l squared which is 2
squared which is 4 times e to the
negative 1 so it's 4 over e which you
can pop into your calculator and get
that value now if that's where that is i
better make sure like if that's 1 then i
guess 2 would be there so i need to be
somewhere about here right these are
little points of detail and attention
that you need you can't just put your
station point wherever you like right so
i'm guessing something like that
that's pretty turning pointy right and
then what i just established from there
is that i'm going to be approaching zero
right so it reflects
downwards
like so do we have to do the outside
here uh and yes i would need to finish
that off i just need to put in that
point there one
one
and then in part c i want to go lay you
know a layer at this point over here and
i'm approaching y equals zero
okay